[Music]
Kyler's I just want to congratulate you
your family that getting drafted
Arizona's a really special place and
you're playing a little here I couldn't
be more excited to become a dolphin I'm
ready to attack this new chapter in my
life and give you guys everything I have
each and every day my bags are packed
and I'm on a flight first thing tomorrow
morning
so get ready South Florida go Finn's
Tyler one more thing an awesome
two-bedroom in Old Town just came on to
the market so let me know if you're
interested and I think I can get you a
pretty good deal that's Josh Rosen his
farewell message to the fans in Arizona
plus an offer to Kyler Marie who is
going to be looking for a place to live
and Rosen looking for a place to sell as
he heads to Miami traded during round
two to the Dolphins for pic number 62 it
became Massachusetts receiver Andy
Isabella and also a fifth round pick in
2020 originally the Cardinals wanted pic
number 48 but the Dolphins traded down
with the Saints they needed a max hunger
replacement it's Center and the Saints
sprang up and got one and the Dolphins
picked up a second-round pick from the
Saints next year to do that so very
savvy manipulation of the board Chris by
the Miami Dolphins to still get Rosen
yeah to turn that pick 48 into a second
round or next year I and and to be in
position where they can evaluate Rosen
under contract for three years at 6.2
million that's a great deal and I think
the Dolphins at least have a chance to
be competitive without Rosen I think
it's a potential disaster for Miami this
year with Rosen they've got a shot to be
competitive yeah definitely I mean first
of all like you said I do want to give
credit to that savvy move by the
Dolphins there and realizing that they
kind of got Arizona where they want them
and that you know Arizona is desperate
to get rid of a Josh Rosen and the
knowing that they're one of the only
teams that were in conversations to get
Rosen in general so I'm sure they
figured out okay if they'll accept pick
48 they'll probably accept pick 62 to go
along with it but I do think it's a
great move by the Miami Dolphins I mean
again they might strike you know gold
here with Josh Rosen certainly Josh
Rosen fits exactly what Miami wants to
do offensively again it's Chad O'Shea
he's a wide receivers coach who's been
up in New England for a long long time
they want pocket passers of course in
New England that are you know smart able
to make good decisions and really
accurate throws Rosen is extremely
accurate thrower the football Mike and
hey they get a basically a year trial
period here for a second round pick to
figure out okay if this guy's the future
of their franchise and they'll be able
to figure out between now and the 2020
draft if he's the guy or if they need to
get back in the market for another
franchise quarterback next year and
Rosen has handled the situation so
incredibly well he went to the Larry
Fitzgerald charity softball game stayed
an extra day for it got a standing
ovation won the home run derby was named
MVP of the game he's become one of the
most sympathetic figures in football by
doing nothing it's amazing but for this
Steve Smith rant which I think was a
little on the kooky side yeah everybody
else out there has been all in for Josh
Rosen Chris yeah no they have you're
right and I mean again I know where
Steve Smith was coming from a little bit
you know I'm glad one of his does well
yeah it was a little harsh there's no
question about that
you know I guess he's trying to tell
Josh Rosen who's you know kind of got a
stigma already some people thought he
was you know bratty and he thinks too
much outside the box and all that crap
that you heard about him last year in
the draft so that stigmas there and then
when he unfollowed Arizona you know it
looked a little petty I get you there
but I don't know if Steve Smith had to
go off on him the way he did but either
way you know again I think Arizona did
the right thing here - yeah would they
have liked to got a little bit more
value for Josh Rosen certainly but you
want to start off the Kingsbury Kyler
Murray era smoothly and you know for
Josh Rosen they got a wide receiver that
really fits a position that they need
Danny Isabella is like a Wes Welker or a
Julian Edelman type of guy and quick
Kingsbury when he was at Texas Tech and
I was at Texas he was throwing - Wes
Welker in that same offense so that
makes sense for them as well where do
you put Rosen if he'd have been
available in the draft this year with
the four guys that went yeah one - 40 -
where do you put rows yeah you know so
early on when I first watched them I
thought oh okay it Skyler Murray then
Rosen
the more I watched I think I would have
gone drew Locker Dwayne Haskins then
Rosen he would have been my fourth guy
so basically you're saying the giant
shoulda trade for him not the dolphin
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports